BUT NUMBER ONE THE VICTORY OF
THIS TAX REFORM AND A WHOLE LOT
MORE COMING UP.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU, LAURA.
IT'S A GREAT DAY FOR AMERICA.
>> Laura: A HISTORIC DAY, THE
LAST TIME WAS DURING THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION.
TELL ME THE MOOD IN THE
WEST WING TODAY AFTER A LONG
BATTLE.
>> I THINK ALL OF US JUST FELT
VERY GRATEFUL.
GRATEFUL FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
STRONG LEADERSHIP.
OR SOMEBODY WHO LITERALLY RAN ON
A COMMITMENT TO REVIVE THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FORGOTTEN
MEN AND WOMEN OF THIS COUNTRY OR
YEAR LONG AS HE FOUGHT, NOT ONLY
FOR THE LARGEST TAX CUT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, WHICH PASSED
TODAY, BUT FOR THE KIND OF
REGULATORY REFORM, ROLLING BACK
FEDERAL RED TAPE.
RELEASING OF AMERICAN ENERGY,
ALL THE THINGS THAT HAVE ALREADY
REVIVED THE AMERICAN ECONOMY,
BUT TO BE HERE FOR THE LARGEST
TAX CUT IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY, THE KIND OF TAX REFORM
WE HAVEN'T SEEN FOR 31 YEARS AND
AT THE SAME TIME TO REPEAL THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE AND OBAMACARE
AND OPEN UP AND        UP TO ENN
AND OPEN UP AND        UP TO ENE
AND OPEN UP AND        UP TO ENT
AND OPEN UP AND        UP TO ENL
AND OPEN UP AND        UP TO ENY
>> Laura: REPUBLICANS ARE
ALWAYS KNOWN TO BE DEFICIT
HAWKS, BUT THIS LEGISLATION BY
MOST DON'T LIKE MOST ESTIMATES
DOES INCREASE THE DEFICIT BY
ABOUT $1.5 TRILLION.
WHAT ABOUT THAT OVER TEN YEARS?
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT THAT
AND DOES THAT MEAN WE WILL BE
TACKLING ENTITLEMENTS AS
PAUL RYAN IS ALWAYS WANTING TO
DO?
>> THE NEED FOR THE CONGRESS TO
ALWAYS LOOK FOR WAYS TO TIGHTEN
ITS BELT IS A REAL PRIORITY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE ESTIMATES OF DEFICITS HERE
ARE ALL BASED ON SOME PRETTY
PREDICTABLE GROWTH ESTIMATES
GOING FORWARD.
>> Laura: TAX POLICY
FOUNDATION SAYS IT DOES TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT GROWTH, EVEN IF THE
TAX CUTS ARE PERMANENT, THEY SAY
IT AS ABOUT 1.4, 1.5.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, BUT I HAVE TO
TELL YOU PRESIDENT TRUMP REALLY
MORE OF WHAT THEY EARN, BY
LOWERING TAXES ON BUSINESSES
LARGE AND SMALL THAT WE WILL
OUTPERFORM THOSE GROWTH
THE KIND OF FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN DRIVING
>> Laura: WHY IS THE PUBLIC
NOT WITH THIS BILL?
POLLING, I'M DOUBTFUL OF SOME OF
THE POLLING, BUT PRETTY MUCH
EVERY POLL PUTS IT BETWEEN ABOUT
33% AND 42% POPULARITY OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
HOW DO YOU GUYS GO OUT ARROW TO
EVERY PART OF THE COUNTRY AND
SELL THIS AS A TAX CUT FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS EVEN THOUGH THE TOP
20 PERCENT DO GET THE LION'S
SHARE OF THE RELIEF?
>> IS THE PRESIDENT DID TODAY ON
THE SOUTH LAWN, WE WILL CONTINUE
TO MAKE THE CASE FOR THIS
MIDDLE-CLASS MIRACLE.
WANT TO CUT TAXES FOR EVERY
AMERICAN.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE SOME WORK
TO DO TO SELL THIS?
>> MAYBE A LITTLE BIT.
WHEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE START
TO SEE MORE IN THEIR PAYCHECKS
IN FEBRUARY THEY WILL START TO
REALIZE THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
VISION HERE, THAT THIS
MIDDLE-CLASS MIRACLE THAT WAS
PASSED TODAY BY THE CONGRESS WAS
AN IDEA WHOSE TIME HAS COME.
I REALLY BELIEVE IT WILL SELL
ITSELF.
>> Laura: CARRIED INTEREST
BENEFITS HAD SPONGE.
THEY GET TO HAVE THEIR PROFITS
TAXED AT A MUCH LOWER RATE THAN
MOST AMERICANS.
THAT SURVIVES IN THIS
LEGISLATION.
TO THE BIG HEDGE FUND FORCE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
I UNDERSTAND THE PRESIDENT
WANTED IT OUT OF THE LEGISLATION
WANTED IT OUT OF THE LEGISLATIO
LEGISLATION.
WHICH REPUBLICANS DEMANDED THAT
IT STAY IN?
>> THE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE BEEN
HAPPY TO SEE IT COME OUT.
>> Laura: DID HE GO TO THE MAT
ON THAT?
WHY SHOULD HEADPHONES GUYS GET
THE CONTINUED BENEFIT OF A LOW
TAX RATE?
HOW DOES THAT LOOK TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS?
>> I THINK WHAT HE WENT TO THE
MAT ON WAS REALLY JUST ADVANCING
AT 3% GROWTH IN PEOPLE TOLD THE
PRESIDENT DURING THE CAMPAIGN,
THEY LAUGH AT HIM AND SAID IT
WOULD TAKE YEARS TO GET 3%.
HE GOT THERE BY THE THIRD
QUARTER OF THIS YEAR AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO SEE GROWTH.
I TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE COMPANIES THAT HAD
TOO MANY INCENTIVES IN OUR OLD
TAX CODE TO TAKE JOBS OVERSEAS
AND YOU'LL START SEEING JOBS
JOBS AND AMERICAN WORKERS AND WE
WILL SEE OUR ECONOMY EXPAND.
>> Laura: ARE YOU SURPRISED
THAT YOU DIDN'T GET ONE
DEMOCRATIC VOTE, NOT ONE?
>> I AM ACTUALLY.
>> Laura: I FIND IT TO BE
ACTUALLY STUNNING.
EVEN AS PARTISAN AS THINGS ARE,
NOT A SINGLE -- AND WAS THERE
ANYTHING THAT REPUBLICANS COULD
HAVE DONE?
JOE MANCHIN SAID IT WAS ALL
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, WHICH IS
NOT ACCURATE, BUT HE SAID HE HAD
A LIST OF THINGS THAT WERE NEVER
CONSIDERED.
>> LAURA, LOOK, I WATCHED
PRESIDENT TRUMP RING DEMOCRAT
>> Laura: WHAT DIDN'T WORK?
>> FOR MEETINGS, FOR MEALS TO
SIT DOWN AND SAY WE WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE MAJORITY OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE,
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE SIGNED A
LETTER TAKING THEMSELVES
COMPLETELY OUT OF THE EQUATION.
THAT'S A DISAPPOINTMENT, NOT
JUST TO OUR ADMINISTRATION BUT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I PROMISE YOU -- YOU KNOW THIS
PRESIDENT WELL.
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO REACH
OUT ACROSS THE AISLE.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEXT YEAR,
REBUILD AMERICA.
>> Laura: YOU WANT PAUL
WRITING TO SAY AS HOUSE SPEAKER?
THERE WAS SOME SCUTTLEBUTT THAT
HE MIGHT BE LEAVING SOONER THAN
PEOPLE THOUGHT.
>> I THINK THE RESULT OF THIS
TAX CUT REALLY FOR ITSELF AND
THE PRESIDENT AND I HOLD HIM IN
THE HIGHEST REGARD AND WANT HIM
TO STAY IN THE CONGRESS AND
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE CONGRESS
BECAUSE WE ARE REALLY JUST
DO MEDICARE REFORM OR IS THAT
JUST TOO BIG OF A HILL TO CLIMB
ONCE AGAIN?
>> FIRST OFF, THE PRESIDENT MADE
IT CLEAR DURING THE CAMPAIGN WE
WILL NOT BE CUTTING
SOCIAL SECURITY.
>> Laura: NO CUTS, NO CHANGES.
>> ON THE HEALTH CARE BILL THAT
WE CAN CLOSE ON A COUPLE OF
TIMES WAS FUNDAMENTAL REFORM IN
MEDICAID.
THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE CAN FIND
SAVINGS AND EVEN IMPROVE
SERVICES TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
AMERICANS IN THESE PROGRAMS AND
I PROMISE YOU WHETHER IT'S
MEDICAID OR OTHER AREAS.
>> Laura: MEDICARE,
SOCIAL SECURITY, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO TOUCH THOSE OF THE
FIRST TERM.
>> HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR ON THOSE
ISSUES.
A GROWING ECONOMY AND FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY GIVING STATES
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO ADMINISTER
PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICAID IS A
GROW OUR WAY OUT OF $20 TRILLION
IN DEBT?
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO HAS A
BOUNDLESS OPINION ABOUT THE
CAPACITY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THE STRENGTH OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THIS YEAR ALONE WHERE
THE ECONOMY IS COMING BACK,
OPTIMISM IS BACK, AND ALL OF
THAT IS BEFORE TODAY AS THIS TAX
CUT TAKES EFFECT AND TAKES HOLD.
AS PEOPLE BEGIN TO FEEL THE
FREEDOM FROM THAT MANDATE AND
OBAMACARE THAT WAS REPEALED.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
FOR THE LAST SEVEN YEARS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE HAD TO PAY
A TAX FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF NOT